In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for May 11 on which we commemorate our Holy Father's
Cyril and Methodius equal to the Apostles and Evangelizers of the Slavs.
On this day we celebrate the memory of our Holy Father's Cyril Constantine and Methodius
equal to the Apostles and Evangelizers of the Slavs.
These new Apostles were born into a noble family in Thessalonica, a city which, being at the
crossroads of various peoples, had been strongly influenced by the Slavs in the 9th century.
The two brothers had, from childhood, been in contact with the Slav peoples who had settled
in the region, learning their dialect and becoming used to their customs.
The Thodios, the elder, born in 815, was of a calm and gentle character.
He acquired a solid legal knowledge and quickly showed such great aptitude for administration
that he was given the government of a province inhabited by Slavs.
He nevertheless realized, after several years, that he should not be wasting time in concern
for things that are not of eternal value and resigned.
Fleeing from the world as a sparrow flees the hunter's snare, he reached the prestigious
monastic center of Mount Olympus in Bethinia, where he became an exemplary monk, both by
his obedience and love of prayer, and also his application to the study of the scriptures.
Born in 827, was gifted by God with an exceptional intelligence and memory, and dreamed from
his earliest years of espousing not a beautiful princess, but the wisdom of God, like a second
Solomon.
At the age of 14, he had learned the poems of St. Gregory the Theologian by heart, and
begged his teachers with tears to teach him the grammar of the Homeric dialect, so that
he could penetrate their sense.
The young boys' talents gained such renown that they were heard of by the all-powerful
Legothetus the Octastus, who summoned him to Constantinople and took him under his protection.
Constantine quickly completed his general studies and was initiated into higher sciences by
the best masters of the time, Leo the mathematician, and St. Fotius, whose beloved disciple he became.
With Fotius, he learned where to find true wisdom, the knowledge of things divine and human
which teaches man to conduct himself in all things in the image and likeness of his creator.
He was known as the Philosopher, and becoming familiar with the highest court circles was
reckoned by the Octastus to be destined for a brilliant political career, to be inaugurated
by marriage to one of his nieces.
The Philosopher thanked him for his suggestion, but replied that nothing meant anything to him
but to acquire knowledge and to recover the glory lost by our first father.
He had, though, to accept ordination to the deaconate and was given the dignity of Kartofelak's
to patriarch Ignatius.
However, he abandoned this situation very soon to withdraw to a monastery on the Bosphorus,
the Glideon, where he met the dethroned iconoclast patriarch John VII Grammaticus and engaged
with him in fiery controversy over the defense of Orthodoxy.
After six months, he was recalled to the capital and was forced under pressure from the Octastus
to accept the post of Professor of Philosophy.
In 851, when he was 24, the Emperor Michael III sent him on a diplomatic mission to Caliph
Al-Muthawakul, discussions with the Arabs rapidly turned from politics to theology, and
it was with the assurance of the early martyrs that Constantine made an Apologia for the Holy
Trinity before their wise men, showing them the superiority of Christian principles.
Barely escaping an attempt to poison him, he was able to return safe and sound to Byzantium.
In Caesar Bartus, at Constantine's protector, the Octastus assassinated, in order to take
power in 855, he, again, abandoning the cares of the world to seek wisdom and silence and
prayer, went to join his brother Methodius on Mount Olympus, where they together devoted
themselves to study.
In 860, the Emperor, having consulted with patriarch Fotius, called Constantine back from his
retreat to send him on a mission to the Khan of the Khazars, who had asked him to send
him an educated man to discuss religious matters with the Jews and Arabs who were trying
to convert his people.
Accompanied by his brother, and an imposing entourage, the philosopher learned Hebrew on
the journey and was miraculously given a knowledge of the Samaritan dialect.
With the Khazar court, they held long theological discussions with the Jews, and Constantine
confounded the doctors of the law, showing them the superiority of the gospel, and thus obtaining
the conversion of many dignitaries, and also the freeing of Christian captives.
After having signed a treaty of alliance with the Khan, the two brothers set off homeward,
burning on the way the pagan peoples of Tauric Cursonies.
They also took St. Clemens' relics, which they had discovered in a miraculous way, in
Cursonises, Stavastopol, back with them to Rome.
Immediately after he had given his report to the Emperor, Constantine withdrew into Hisikia
and prayer near the Church of the Holy Apostles.
Portias, having refused the episcopal consecration that was offered him, had nevertheless to accept
the post of Abbot of the Monastery of Polycronion, where 70 monks were living at that time.
This return to their beloved quietude lasted a very short time.
In 863, an embassy sent by Rastislav, Prince of Moravia, arrived in Constantinople to ask
the Emperor for a bishop and a teacher capable of instructing them in their language in the
Christian faith that they had initially received in part from Frankish missionaries from Bavaria.
These latter preached in Latin and celebrated a liturgy that was incomprehensible.
This resulting in few conversions and the keeping by the people were the most part of their
idolatrous customs.
Michael II replied to them,
It is not for me to dictate your faith, and he refused to give them a bishop, not wishing
to usurp this region that was under the jurisdiction of the Pope of Rome.
But he promised to send them men capable of instructing them in the doctrine of salvation
in their own language without seeking to impose the Greek language on them.
The philosopher was the only man who possessed all the requisite qualities for this mission,
not only by his wisdom, but also because of his knowledge of the Bulgarian dialect and
the principle languages of the time, Greek, Latin, Hebrew, Arabic, or more precisely the Turkokasar
language, Syriac and Samaritan.
The philosopher accepted this mission as a command from God, but asked for some time in which
to prepare, and turning to prayer, as was his custom, he begged of God the revelation of
the script that was capable of rendering the sounds of the Slav language in an acceptable
way.
In the same way in which the old covenant was revealed to Moses on Sinai, after a revelation
of God on tablets of stone inscribed by his hand, so Constantine, this second Moses,
believed the revelation of a new alphabet, with which he was able at once to write a Slav
translation of the first verses of the Gospel according to St. John.
It was these writings that, after study and correction, became the instrument by which the
Slav peoples, until then barbarians and men of gross habits, were able to be placed by the
holy missionaries in the ranks of civilized peoples, who praised God in their own language.
Helped by Methodos and other disciples of Slav origin, St. Constantine urgently translated
the Gospel readings for the whole year, the Divine Liturgy, the Book of Hours, and
the Psalter, and it was thus furnished with the instruments that were vital to their apostolic
work, that the Byzantine missionaries left for Moravia in 863.
They were received with great honor at Rastus Slav's court, and he put a group of disciples
under their guidance to beat taught the new scriptures.
The use of the Slav language in the celebration of the holy mysteries and in preaching, the
faithfulness of their apostolic teaching and the radiant sanctity of the two brothers assured
the rapid success of the mission, and in less than three years they had gathered together
more than a hundred disciples, who in their turn spread the good news throughout the kingdom.
But this success provoked jealousy and opposition from the Frankish missionaries, who, seeing
their influence rapidly overshadowed by that of the Byzantines, denounced them for celebrating
the liturgy in Slavonic, although it was only permitted, they said, in Greek, Latin,
or Hebrew.
Once the first foundations of their enterprise had been laid, the two brothers decided
to return to Constantinople, to ordain there their chief disciples.
But the road being blocked because of the deterioration of relations between Byzantium and Bulgaria,
they decided to go to Venice and take the sea route.
While the missionaries were waiting to charter a ship, the local clergy took up against them
the same accusations that the Frankish missionaries had used.
The matter was referred to Pope Nicholas I who summoned them to Rome.
When they arrived, bearing as a gift the relics of Saint Clement, the people gave them an
enthusiastic welcome.
Pope Adrian II, who had just been elected after the sudden death of Nicholas, approved the
work of the two apostles and solemnly placed their translation of the Holy Books on the
altar of Santa Maria Maggiore, condemning their accusers, the triglycites, three language
users.
He then himself ordained Methodius and three of their disciples to the priesthood, and
on the following days they were all able to celebrate in Slavonic in many of the city's
churches.
During this stay at Rome, Constantin, exhausted by the journeys and labors of the mission,
fell seriously ill, and on the 14th of February in 869, after having received the monastic
habit under the name Cyril, gave his apostolic soul into God's hands, praying for the confirmation
of the Slav peoples in the Orthodox faith.
He was buried with great honor in the Basilica of St. Clement, and miracles were later worked
at his tomb.
Kosoel, prince of Pannonia, admiring the work of these Byzantine missionaries in Moravia
and himself desiring to remove his people from the influence of the Bavarian missionaries
from Pusau, had suggested to them when they passed through his country on the way to Venice
that he can fight to them the formation of 50 disciples.
Shortly after St. Cyril's death, Kosoel sent messengers to Rome, asking that Methodius
be sent to him without delay, and Pope Adrian exceeded to this request.
After a highly successful first mission, Methodius returned to Rome to the Pope to be consecrated
Bishop of Syrmium, now Stremska Mitrovica, a sea that had been founded earlier by the Holy
Apostle Andronicus, with jurisdiction not only over Pannonia, but all the Slav peoples of
Central Europe, with whose conversion he was entrusted in 870.
In the midst of afflictions and labors, the saint unstinctingly continued his work of evangelization,
as his main teaching instrument that translated divine liturgy which gave the Neophytes the nourishment
necessary for their spiritual growth.
He ordained priests and deacons, and, thanks to his administrative experience, was able
to give this new church the canonical foundations of its organization.
But when he arrived in Moravia in 873, the situation had greatly changed.
His vetoplock had seized power after having Rastislav blinded, and had once again given the
country over to German influence.
Methodius had only just arrived when he was arrested and made to appear before Asinid in Bavaria,
which, after a travesty of a judgment, had him shut in a tower in Suav, where he suffered
cruelly from the rigors of the climate.
It was only after two and a half years that Pope John VIII was advised of the situation
and was able to set the saint free.
As soon as he returned to Moravia, Methodius took up his work again with increased zeal,
ignoring the ban against celebrating the liturgy in Slavonic.
He did not hesitate to reprimand Svetoplock severely for his ill-regulated behavior, and
uncompromisingly opposed the erroneous doctrine of the Filioque, which the Frankish clergy
were attempting to impose in this missionary land.
The Franks appealed to Rome, but Methodius, within Apologia to the Pope for his actions,
in 879, returned in triumph with the confirmation of all his rights, to the confusion of his sworn
enemy leaking the suffrage in Bishop of Nida.
The latter never seized his intrigues, a next time accused the saint of rebellion against
the Emperor.
This new trial was for Methodius an opportunity to travel to Constantinople to give Emperor
Basil the First and Patriarch Fotius news of his mission and to assure them of his unshakeable
faithfulness in 881.
He was received at court with great deference, and both sovereign and patriarch strongly
approved the mission and work of the new apostles.
Comforted by this support from the Great Church, Methodius returned to Moravia with his disciples.
And it was in peace and tranquility with no more interference from the Frankish clergy
that they continued their translation of the Church's books.
Methodius completed the translation of the whole Bible in six months, together with
patristic texts and books of the Holy Cannons, all of which were necessary to the Slav Church
for its assimilation of the Byzantine Christian heritage.
Once this work was completed, Methodius gathered his disciples together and celebrated a solemn
liturgy and honor of Saint Demetrius.
He then appointed his successor, Saint Gorast, who a native of Moravia had acquired a perfect
knowledge of Greek, and after having blessed the kings and the people gave his soul to God
in peace on the 6th of April in 885.
His funeral was solemnized in Greek, Latin, and Slavonic in the presence of an uncountable
crowd that accompanied him with candles, weeping for their master and good shepherd who had
made himself all things to all men in order to lead them all to salvation.
The disappearance of the Apostle of the Slavs gave, wicking, and his adherence the opportunity
to resume their conspiracy against the Byzantine missionaries.
He got to Rome before Gorast and succeeded in convincing Pope Stephen V of Methodius'
heterodoxy, and it was armed with a letter giving him with full powers that he returned
to Moravia.
With the support of Svetloplok, who had little interest in theological matters, the felon
launched a merciless persecution of Methodius' disciples.
Gorast, Clement, and more than 200 other Holy Confessers.
Some were beaten and dragged through briars.
The youngest were sold as slaves to Venetian merchants, and others were exiled to the furthest
extremities of the kingdom.
Gorast found refuge in Poland, others in Bohemia, and Clement, Nahum, Savus, Angelarius,
and Lawrence managed to reach Bulgaria, where they were welcomed as angels of God by Zarboris.
Their persecutors found just punishment for their conduct, because in 907 Moravia was invaded
and ravaged by the Hungarians, passing definitively from then on under Latin domination.
The work of the two brothers equal to the apostles Cyril and Methodius left no trace on
this earth.
But through the intermediary of the Bulgarian church, it became the seed of a rich Byzantine
tradition that found its apogee in Kievan Russia after the conversion of St. Vladimir.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.